where is Singapore the bachelor heads to
Singapore and so does the drama
Fraser hanok you think I'm the cancer of
the house Colton and the remaining women
jetted off during week 4 of the dating
competition show and it was tense there
were not one but two confrontations
between the women's first up pageant
queens and frenemies Kalyn and Hanabi we
had a tiff and I think it's okay for us
to be a little upset there is no getting
around it but it's hard enough as women
why not be supporter of one another
let's put the past in the past let's
squash this once and for all it's just
like it's done Taoiseach and Kalyn
snagged the one-on-ones while Colton's
group date had a whopping 13 women and
that's what I'm looking forward to Demi
shared a shocking revelation about her
mom my mom was released from federal
prison and Courtney lost her cool on
Demi not once but twice
oh stop it I just feel like sometimes
your actions and behavior it's just kind
of like solidifying a maturity level
people have ever said to me in my life
no class which eventually seem to get
her sent home earlier in the night
things got serious on Kaitlyn's solo
date when she opened up about an
extremely difficult time in her life so
four years ago as the software in
college it was actually four years spent
October so me and during my girlfriends
went to one of my friends houses and
they they dropped our wine I woke up
next morning and I was completely naked
in my bed and have no memory of the
night before I've been through hell and
back but I think every time I open up
and makes me stronger
et caught up with Colton earlier this
month where he dished about finding love
on TV it's a roller coaster of emotions
but there's just a lot of emotions that
go into finding love obviously but
there's a lot of emotion that went into
filming the show too
[Music]